and this is a mutual news submit if I
get in the zone our case study reveals
why a woman started lactating from her
vulva that's what your bless your [ __ ]
right section your vulva is your vagina
I read what port the bull was the
outside part what part the outside the
lips yes so she's like drooling so it
could be like yeah that where the hairs
come out like maybe that's an infection
mm-hmm she's lactating lactating milk
milk who tried it so was there a milk
mustache there just 29 year old girl
from Austria who just gave birth to her
second child and she actually tore when
she gave birth so they had to sew her so
her [ __ ] wave a wand yeah so she she
received two sets of stitches in two
different parts of her vagina area and
so over time she started experiencing a
lot of pain and swelling and so she went
to the doctor oh she also developed a
discharge of milky white fluid and so
this is on day four after giving birth
where was him milky white fluid was
coming out of her veg bilaterally on the
vulva through the milk has one job come
out the boob well you would think right
you [ __ ] up but because of this
article I learned something new
mmm there is a milk wine Wow the milk
line happening so this is the line oh
[ __ ]
that's a nice ass body I know and so
when babies are being developed and like
and either forming this is how sometimes
some people might get but their nipple
because it's down the line
it looks like they drew vagina split but
then there was like do graphic do
graphic erasing know like little V thing
yeah but yes so she actually has memory
glands in her boy don't we have that it
looks like a poor [ __ ] [ __ ] crazy
that none of us knew this down there
yeah why is that even if you have to
collect all the hormones to give to the
TV
maybe yeah yeah yeah are you know how
dogs I have Helen nipples maybe like the
were like it came like you used to have
that many nipples we used to give oh my
god we have to spend more money on
clothes getting like three boob jobs at
a time I'm taking it like I'm saving for
my third yes so what ended up happening
that they realized is that she by having
those stitches okay so for the first
time she gave birth the [ __ ] calm down I
think this is the first I know it's
interrupting her she's like tell me to
calm down damn it welcome you
interrupted yourself with suspected it
will all be quiet for at least the next
30 seconds three okay and her the first
time that she gave birth I'm still like
scared of anything interrupted okay the
first time she gave birth she did
experience similar symptoms where she
was like like her whole vulva was like
swollen and she was having this
discharge stuff she didn't really know
what it was but because giving birth
this time she had to have stitches it
blocked those milk ducts from happening
so she doesn't have a nipple but there
is a duct and so it was being blocked
wait I go she is over nipple we did we
covered that
nirisha spores Oh from a vagina I was
like she's missing a nipple it's got a
fridge it I think no wonder it had to
come out of supplements strictly about
her vagina like her vulva okay her vulva
doesn't have a nipple got it got it got
a nipple but it does have a duct and so
it was that's where the milk was coming
out and so because of that stitching
that's what it caused the
the flamish and it ended up being crazy
to the point where she's need to go to
the doctor but that's how they
discovered that she had this memory
tissue memory glands so that was when
they discovered that um all women have
it like is that normal or not normal
they're saying that this isn't as crazy
and like unusual like this has happened
in the past okay but it's not like
everybody has that no no okay oh no I
mean everyone has that like everyone's
created with that milk line okay then we
have the pipeline we don't necessarily
have a duct way in
yeah okay defunct but then hers like
like a politic topic breast tissue
because ectopic means it's liking the
different doesn't belong there it's
supposed to be so everybody has it has
the line underneath it yeah so like we
have things we have it yeah yeah it's
like a road that no one drives on that's
weird
usually the milks like I don't get off
on any of these stops and I think I get
up here kids on anime please I load the
diagram like on the top of the diagram
we know something called the memory grew
a rich memory rich memory
what's the Ridge Ridge Oakridge Ridge I
can see Bridge Ridge memory Ridge or
memory crest Graham raikage that's the
natural milk lines in the human body but
there okay so we're seeing milk lines
but I hope a scientist can comment below
the milks not actually traveling because
in my head I was like well so we have
these kind of like DNA like things right
but like milks not going to your [ __ ]
and then coming back up no wonderful
tastes so good
that's gross so they're saying that what
when you put it like that Stacy honey
she's like gross don't have a baby out
your vagina gross that's a baby I just
can only imagine I mean like you already
like are going through a lot they ripped
you open they sew you back up now you
have [ __ ] milk coming out he's been
eating from though the whole time is
video from your placenta it's a lie it's
a lie violence I'm overwhelmed
unless she breastfeeds down here is baby
didn't eat your placenta you crazy it's
like a cannibal baby just like eating
their pregnant why don't they tell you
this like say hey there's like a milk
line you know anything they are saying
that the milk lines appear in a seventh
week of embryonic development
the doctors are like don't tell them
anything they don't know this happens
before human sexual differentiation okay
okay let's say you just gave birth and
then you got a paper cutter reading this
Wikipedia page about memory Ridge it's
they're saying that the lines begin to
shorten and the cells begin to divide
and grow and so yeah so it's not like if
there's probably nothing there now
because we're grown adults well we don't
we're not we didn't just give birth it's
better us 25 so yeah so they're saying
this is why males have nipples because
that's the milk lines up here before
before your manner if you're gonna be a
man or a woman they could breastfeed
instead of us yeah I've heard that I've
heard that some men can like they can
yeah even men that have that get on that
jump on here boys they can mighty well
maybe yes and women have the exact same
parts it's just used differently like
the ovaries those are the guys balls and
then like the penis that's well they
bleed oh no right oh we gotta have the
uterus
I do PMS though they do yeah they're on
a cycle for sure we're sure they are and
it sucks because you can't prove it
because they don't bleed solely for the
other day Bart woke up and he was
getting his [ __ ] ready to go work out
and start his day and then so I thought
he left he's left the room and I was
still in bed and then he comes in he
goes I'm having a bad day always putting
my stuff away and like I got my protein
bottle and then it just shut it alright
we should actually track it oh yeah we
should like secretly get a second period
tracker on your phone app like figure
out some EMF you just put it your Google
Calendar but like don't tell them cuz
they'll try to cheat the system and
pretend they don't have it on that way
you have to like do it in secret mark it
with secret letter like I wonder what
happens to them because you know how I
just said that guys and girls have the
same part but used differently what's
their uterus they don't have one I mean
we'll think a lot of things change after
like yes that's certainwy she went yeah
that certain gestation week a lot of
extra shit's happening like a whole
different chromosome than we do and they
go in and then there's goes out so their
uterus end up in a baby wallet I suggest
they do mom this is weird this is a very
common situation
gestating is that the word you're caught
up on that's the pregnancy yeah yeah
yeah yeah no I just didn't know what you
were saying cuz she's saying like why
don't guys have exactly the opposite of
us whatever you imagine parts except the
uterus cuz like a lot is they can't have
babies in it's like the same and then it
changes a lot yeah yeah cuz we don't
come like like one and never prove that
one through that's how come we don't
have the thing that makes sperm like
yeah yeah like what happened to ours and
they don't get titties some do Oh
only when they know us I'm actually you
tofu some kids actually have like that
normality and like I've seen like Athene
on YouTube though I titties what so I
guess SOI has like a phytoestrogen which
is like something that mimics estrogen
and that's why like it some it's been
debunked by some places but then like
some people they eat a lot of soya like
some guys they they do have ditties so I
don't know interesting yeah especially
when they're younger like there I saw
like a thing on YouTube this kid like
who like had to have like a to remove
his breast yeah because he's like in
middle school and I already spunky him
and you know it's like hella rough those
times you know so here punking them cuz
they're feeling a type of way Bobby when
Bobby's around my [ __ ] pants feel fun
was he overweight no he was like a
skinny kid yeah lucky Kelly different
and we're shed by the city's just that
lucky boys like in middle probably like
yeah think that it's how you said it I
was just like damn I to pay for my guy
never got mine so I had him and they
went away anyone else say what else my
paint on my I wore DS in high school and
they're like it which is well would also
be what are your chunky back I was but
then like for a while I lost weight in
my waist but my boobs stayed a C and
then went through another weight cycle
they were I can yeah when I would lose
weight my tits were the first thing ago
and I'm like I have so much [ __ ] fat
everywhere else why am I kidding
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]